[Música]
y en salud hoy dejamos la pandemia de
kobe 19 de un lado para hablar de otra
pandemia la organización mundial de la
salud lanzó una campaña para concienciar
sobre las epidemias de meningitis y
fomentar la investigación para combatir
esta enfermedad
precisamente estamos allá en el estudio
con más romeros a la nuestra periodista
de salud mar bienvenida un gusto
saludarles muy buen día muy buen día
raúl vamos a hablar de esto precisamente
la meningitis antes que nada para hacer
una breve introducción se trata de la
inflamación de la membrana que rodea el
cerebro y rodea la médula espinal esto
puede pasar por muchísimos motivos pero
la más letal es la meningitis provocada
por la infección de bacterias puede
llegar a provocar 250 mil muertes
anuales y precisamente esto es lo que la
oms se quiere reducir de aquí a 2030 y
para hablar de eso estamos con el doctor
oscar franco él es médico epidemiólogo y
director del instituto de medicina
social y preventiva de la universidad de
berna muy buenos días doctor un gusto
volver a tenerlo en france 24 cuéntenos
por qué la meningitis se considera una
epidemia
cuando hablamos de epidemia nos
referimos a una enfermedad que ocurre en
un periodo concreto y una población
concreta y afecta a muchas personas y en
los últimos años hemos tenido muchas
epidemias de meningitis no solamente en
los países pobres sino también los
países ricos pero afecta más
frecuentemente a los países que salen lo
que se ha llamado el cinturón de la
meningitis que son 26 países en el
áfrica sub-sahariana como senegal
camerún y nigeria en latinoamérica
afecta más que todo los niveles más
altos se han reportado en brasil en
uruguay en chile argentina y colombia
estas epidemias suelen ser imprevisibles
y generen unos gastos catastróficos para
el sistema de salud las comunidades y
las personas que son afectadas ahora
doctor los saludo y también le quiero
preguntar cómo se transmite y qué
consecuencias tiene la meningitis
hay varias vías de transmisión una es
por ejemplo la vía respiratoria entonces
cuando se estornuda o cuando se tose
otro es el contagio que ocurre por el
contacto cercano y otro al tocar objetos
que están contaminados la meningitis
puede ser causada ya sea por virus o por
bacterias hongos o por ejemplo parásitos
también lo pueden causar pero lo más
grave es la meningitis causada por
bacterias en el que más o menos 1 de
cada 10 personas afectadas pueden
fallecer y uno de cada cinco que algunas
repercusiones
largas y duraderas como por ejemplo
convulsiones pérdida de la visión de la
audición y problemas cognitivos que
limiten el desarrollo de las personas y
el rendimiento escolar
doctor esta enfermedad afecta
especialmente a los niños y a la
población infantil a qué se debe eso
si afecta principalmente a niños y con
problemas en el sistema inmune pero
puede afectar a cualquier persona de
cualquier edad porque afecta más a los
niños varias razones la primera es
porque los niños suelen estar en los
centros escolares en un contacto más
cercano con otros niños y la higiene que
generalmente no están tan establecidas
ahora si vemos visto durante la pandemia
la segunda razón es porque cuando ya
estamos adultos nos hemos expuesto a
varios de estos patógenos y por lo tanto
tenemos algunas defensas otra razón es
tenemos como adultos suelen tener mejor
acceso a los sistemas de salud y la
cuarta razón es que para poderla
diagnosticar es a veces difícil en los
niños porque les cuesta contarnos que lo
que están sintiendo o que les está
molestando doctor ahora le quiero
preguntar qué tratamientos o vacunas
existen para combatir la meningitis
además le quiero preguntar si son
suficientes
si tenemos varias vacunas pero no son
suficientes para cubrir todos los
posibles causas de esta enfermedad y
hemos visto que durante el commit que si
se hace una inversión adecuada y el
puerto y el esfuerzo adecuado se pueden
generar las vacunas que se necesitan por
lo tanto es este llamado la organización
mundial de la salud para invertir en el
desarrollo de esas vacunas también para
mejorar el acceso al tratamiento que
suele ser antibióticos y otro tipo de
tratamiento especializado y también
mejorar el acceso a programas de
rehabilitación a las personas que ya han
tenido la mente y tish
para terminar doctor yo quiero
preguntarle yo estaba indicando antes
pero porque estos brotes afectan a estos
países que usted le llamaba que incluso
tienen el nombre de cinturón de la
meningitis a qué se debe eso
si generalmente se debe a porque tienen
sistemas de salud un poco menos
seguros menos establecidos que en otros
países se tienen menor acceso al sistema
de salud por lo tanto el diagnóstico
ocurre más tardío tienen peores
programas de vacunación muchas de estas
vacunas que pueden proteger contra la
meningitis pues no las tienen en sus
programas de vacunación y por lo tanto
se llama a todos los países ya todo el
mundo a mejorar esos programas de
inmunización ya mejorar la prioridad que
se le debe dar a la meningitis para
poderlo combatir y reducirla en el 2030
pues doctor gracias por su explicación y
estaré nuevamente con nosotros en salud
de directo américa aquí en france 24 mar
muchísimas gracias a usted también por
pues este esta información sobre la
meningitis